and we do indeed have another guest that
is a gracie prasanna after an incredible
victory first of all gracie welcome to
the show welcome to st louis this is
your first time at the u.s junior girls
how does that feel
what does this tournament mean to you um
it's very exciting like i've heard of
this tournament and i've always kind of
wanted to play in it so being able to
compete against all these amazing
players that i've heard about never like
played in like this big of a menu it's
pretty great take us uh through the
first four games specifically yesterday
it was such a tense battle against the
leader of uh this tournament and then in
the end you resigned in a promised
position
um yeah that was really upsetting
obviously because i thought i was losing
i didn't actually see the queen h6 idea
and
um it's kind of weird because usually i
don't resign in that kind of position
but
yeah i just tried to bounce back from
that i guess
it was strange for us because you played
all the way up to that point with down a
piece and then
you resign when you finally got the
knight but today you bounced back a big
victory for you take us through uh
today's game um i thought that the
position was kind of drawish to be
honest like i was about ready to offer
the job but then i was like well let's
keep playing like worst case like we're
going to go for a threefold so
what i did and then a3 knight takes d4
yes and uh
you came up with this idea knight to f5
to pick up the two bishops
how did you feel the assessment of the
position is at this point
um well i didn't really like that night
on d5 it was kind of like invading my
position i didn't feel that my knight
was doing the same for her position like
i thought she could kind of maneuver her
pieces around it so i just kind of
wanted to
trade that off for the bishop see if i
could do something with that
and
let's keep going when is the next
critical
moment of this game and by the way uh
sorry to interrupt you this game is
indeed
over
melinsky picks up his first victory of
the u.s senior championship for him
congratulations eager
let's keep going
bishop to d2h5 rook to a1 now tell us
the plan behind this move 281 um i mean
here i think i was just trying to make
time control and i was thinking maybe a4
at some point um
try to bring my
rooks over to attack basics spawn but um
i didn't really think that was going to
happen i was trying to make moves at
that point
and then
a big moment came when you played the
move a bishop to e4 let's uh
let's go to that moment did you realize
that she had this move rook takes e4 at
that point let's keep going
right here
did you realize she has no rook thanks
before yeah she does say that
um or was this a mutual blind spot it
seems like yeah probably um yeah that
was that would just be lost for me
i can't believe i missed that
but she took with the bishop and she
gave you another chance not only that
but it does seem like your king is much
better place right yeah were you already
playing for a victory at this point yeah
here i was playing for a victory because
um we could have gone for the threefold
i just tried to
see what would happen if i tried pushing
this pawn here
and i figured that hurricane couldn't
like catch up in time so that's kind of
what i went for she's just way uh too
far a big victory for you uh gracie your
first time at the u.s juniors
championships what are your ambitions
for this event i'm just trying to get
some good games in hopefully get a few
points and just try to enjoy the event
because it's a really big event and i'm
glad to be here definitely a lot of
experience you will gain from this one
congratulations for the victory and
we'll see you in the rest of your games
thank you congratulations gracie well
done